so on the way to manchester we i'm just
about to meet up with liv cook who's a
really good friend of mine and i've been
working with her for a couple of years
and she's got some interesting projects
going on and i'm about to go and visit
one of her projects in manchester so
excited
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
standing with my good friend liv cook
and liv you are killing at the moment in
property thank you i don't know how you
have the time because she's a world
champion freestyle footballer a bbc
presenter a businesswoman an author
congratulations on your new book by the
way thank you and a property investor
and uh this we're at one of our projects
where abouts our way ashton underlying
in manchester so what made you buy this
place it was a mess and no one else was
gonna buy it to be honest with you but
where they saw like a mess i saw
opportunity now when i last came here to
be honest it was a complete wreck it
looked like someone had died in the
property i'm hoping that it's very
different liv i'd love you to show me
around show me what you've done because
it's been about like eight months since
i've been here so firstly it looks
completely different from the outside so
what's happened outside so when i bought
it it was a three bed and it was owned
by a 93 year old it was an absolute
mess i was so glad that you sold it to
me because to be honest i don't think
anyone else estate it was in would have
bought it so if you just look here this
itself is completely new
this was the outhouse and we've knocked
it down put new foundations rebuilt it
all and it's the first of six bedrooms
so the whole property's gone from being
a three bed wreck to six bed ensuite so
you turn this from a three bed to a six
bed with on sweets this did you need
planning permission for this no because
it already existed so we don't need
planning permission for it we thought
we're gonna be quite simple to be honest
i thought we'd just knock it down and
rebuild it nice cheap extension get more
room
um but not quite when we knocked it down
it's a victorian property so it wasn't
built on foundations so we had to redo
the foundations and we couldn't do
normal foundations where you dig two
meters because we would have undermined
the whole of the house we had to build a
raft and do it that way so it was
expensive but they it's sturdy now we
had to re-jig things you can see like
behind us the communal kitchen space
yeah and we have to change everything
and you've been working closely with the
hmo officer in the council to make sure
you've done it you've got permitted
development rights yeah but you've been
working closely with them to make sure
that it it's it's all fitting legally
yeah all right nice and we don't just
fit the hmo requirements for now but
we'll fit them for years to come we're
basically ahead of the game and also you
created a product which is really
valuable that people actually where
people want to live so now you've
officially gone from a property investor
to a property developer i can't wait to
find out how much money you spent on
this project let's go around and show us
what you're doing
nice
oh so different this was a kitchen
previously but it was a wrap yes
this wasn't here so this was a wall yeah
completely separate but obviously we've
rebuilt the outhouse so this little
extension that you've done not only if
you added weight to the house but you've
also considerably added rent yeah
because this is a whole extra room so
what's the vision then what's the vision
for it to brr so buy refurb i guess you
could call it develop now couldn't you
yeah and rent it out to be honest i'm
not going to rent it privately i could
get more there'd be more profit um but
i'm actually going to give it to a
charity i'm still going to get paid
still going to profit yeah not as much
but
why did you go down the route of
social housing i know you've got a
contact in mind as well i also know
you're somebody you you care about you
know helping homeless and giving back uh
you make a lot of money but what was it
that made you decide to go down that
route specifically for this project two
things really the numbers like i'm a
businesswoman i look at the numbers and
the profit wasn't as good but it was
more hands-free so they guarantee no
avoid periods they cover maintenance
there's no management fee but you do
take a lower cut most people probably
wouldn't consider it because of that it
is like significantly lower um how much
how much if you don't mind sharing on
youtube for the guys how much the six
bedrooms
how much rent per month are you
expecting to get assuming you go down
the route of passing it to a charity if
i pass it to the charity i think i'll be
net in profit at 1500 a month okay it's
not bad
if you think about it on the on the
market i'd probably get 500 pounds a
month
per room yeah yeah after all your
mortgage payments and all expenses
you'll be left with a profit of about 1
500 and you'll be giving back and
passing it on to a charity do you know
what sold it to me because the numbers
sounded good but i was still 50 50 and i
went and met the guys my contact with
the social housing and when i sat down
with them honestly samuel everything
changed like listening to what they do
the way they take people from street
homeless to clean and sober and then
into properties like this where they've
got to be employed they've got to be
proven that they're clean and sober and
really just getting their life back on
track changed everything i nearly cried
i nearly cried sat there talking to them
and they've got a nice they've got a
nice communal area here
nice kitchen
and every room has got its own private
bathroom
[Music]
you know what i've loved about this
property the two things that we all say
you can't change in real estate
investing is location and size i mean
location's great it's 20 minutes into
manchester city centre you've got your
shops there you've got your transport
links it's perfect for hmo yeah other
thing size it's a victorian property you
can see the ceiling heights nice rooms
are spacious like the fact i've been
able to convert this from a three bed to
a six bed when i came around last time
it looked totally unattractive people
weren't people were passing on it but
you spotted the opportunity and i think
that's what you've done so well so okay
so two bedrooms downstairs and let's go
upstairs so this one was actually what
got us the extra bedroom people thought
this was going to be a five bed ensuite
because you can see here where your
stood was literally the wall this was a
tiny room so if you looked at it on
paper and per square foot you want to
fit a bedroom but what they didn't see
was that we could pull it out to here
get the square foot there and put our
ensuite in there that's the importance
of configuration you know and you've got
a nice ensuite again in here great
you've done so well thank you
quite fast this is one of my favorite
rooms because of this big window we
literally had to do pretty much
everything really from scratch haven't
you yeah all been plastered
the windows have not been changed a bit
misty this wasn't just this room this
and the next room were all one it was
one big room so i'm gonna split them
into two what did the html officers say
when they came i changed a few things
around yeah yeah in terms of the
planning so it was meant to be six
ensuites but we've actually had to move
one so they've still got a private
bathroom but it's off-suite just because
they've put she hasn't officially put
the requirements of the sizing up yet
but it's going to go up in a few years
like it's going to be article 4 rounding
so you may as well do it properly
exactly yeah yeah okay and this is this
isn't article 4 yet is it no it's not
which is why you're able to get
permitted development yeah i know i'll
just say it looks pretty it looks pretty
safe you know yeah you've got it all
safe if there's a fire or anything and
you've got responsibility as a landlord
to make sure that it is safe and like
you've got all your windows and your
doors and everything talk to me a little
bit about about that well one thing the
hmo officer is very like won't budge on
his safety i'm rightly so so out there
you've got your smoke alarms fire starts
that goes off you've got your 30 minute
fire door what does a 30 minute fight on
me so fire starts you shut this door
it'll take 30 minutes for the fire to
come through right in which time
you know the fire brigade here you've
got your fire escape windows here so
that opens nicely and you survive pretty
much yeah yeah yeah
that's the off-suite bathroom so that
belongs to this room okay still private
and it was meant to be an ensuite so it
was going to be in here right um but
when the hmo officer came around last
she said pretty much if you put the
ensuite in it's just gonna fit the
requirements but in a few years it's not
right and the thing is and ensuite
doesn't count this is something that a
lot of people have misconceptions about
and ensuite doesn't count as the size of
the room so if you've got a room that's
100 square feet and then you've suddenly
got an unsweetened the room is no longer
100 square feet it takes out of the room
so i think that was yeah that was she
advised you probably right then really
they're great to work with like some
people can moan that oh they're making
me do this they've rejected this but at
the end of the day they've got the same
vision as you they want it to be the
best hmo it can be yeah and the safest
everything like that has it been a
nightmare or has it been all right
no it's not a nightmare i've learned a
lot there's been some problems arise
that were quite difficult um but to be
honest like yeah they arose and i lost a
bit of money but i learned a lot so how
much including the extension and
absolutely everything what's the full
refurb cost come out i know we've still
got a carpet and there's a fuse yeah
yeah yeah
it should work out about 85. 85 grams
yeah and you bought it for 165. so all
in let's do the maths it's crunch time
this is to see where the lips made it
work or not so 85
plus 165 which is what you bought so
you're talking a quarter of a million
pounds all in that's a lot of cash
did you have a lamborghini that's a
lamborghini
but but why why choose when you can have
both right
hey all right so did you use did you use
all of your money uh bridging okay i
used bridging as well okay so you
borrowed some of the money you used some
of your money from savings
um so what is the value now slash once
it's been carpeted and tenanted what's
the uh in a week or two when it's
completely done and it looks fresh we
should see minimum 320. 320. next door
just sold for 320 yeah which is nothing
like this and this is going to be on
commercial valuation as well so this is
going to be probably a lot more but even
if it's 320 okay even if it's 320 that's
still that's still 70 000 pounds profit
70 000 pounds profit then you've got
your rent coming in which will make you
should make you about one and a half
thousand pounds a month clean profit
uh presumably you're going to refinance
it yeah let's say it gets valued at 320
which to be honest i think you'll get a
higher evaluation but let's say times
that by 75
that means you're going to pull out 240
leaving just about 10 grand in of course
you've got your stamp duty and a few
bits and bobs but you'll pull out most
of your money should leave about 20 25
000
which isn't bad 1500 profit
really really good and the location's
perfect so onwards and upwards so what's
next what's next i want to go bigger
yeah i want to go bigger i was thinking
i want to do something similar the same
i made an offer on a property very
similar going to do to a from a three
bed to a six bed ensuite hmo and but it
fell through and because of the vendor
but you know what i think that's a sign
i think why why am i staying like the
same level i want bigger we've done
really well i'm really proud of you
thank you well done mate one of the
things you should look at it's really
important before buying a house is look
at what the other properties in the area
are selling for like we've got a lot of
sold this one's for sale so we we did a
lot of research on comparables didn't we
before you bought this you didn't just
go ahead and buy it blindly you knew
what was the refurb going to be went
slightly over the refurb but still you
worked it out you got proper quotes we
knew what the end value was going to be
approximately and we left contingency
so important too many people they work
out the budgets and it's tight imagine
if you were going to make 50 grand and
then your profit went
you thought you were gonna make between
70 and 120 and it's probably looking
more like 70 depending on end value
we'll find out but hey 70 grand still
really good you know so yeah always do
that research i love this as well live
cooking for my name on it of course it's
good that you have because when you put
your name to it you're proud of it i am
proud of it and i'm proud of what it's
going to do and it's how it's going to
help people you know it's hard to walk
around as well with live and not get
recognised but question final question
for the guys watching this like you are
a world champion freestyle footballer
you're a business woman you're a bbc now
you're an author
this is all in the airports and stuff
like what would you say the key thing is
where'd you get that winning streak it's
like now you're succeeding in property
what do you do what's the formula
to win
right i need to read the book right yeah
definitely yeah the way to win if you
could like summarize it to the guys i
think it is a momentous snowball effect
any anything i want to do i pursue it
like if there's an interest something
just captures my attention i want to
learn about it i want to give it a go
and i've got that self-belief to know
that anything i put my mind to i can
make happen and that's not in an
arrogance way that's not me being cocky
saying i'm good at everything i know
everything absolutely not that's me
saying yeah i know i'm a rookie but i
know i'm going to go all in on this i'm
going to put the work in that's needed
and more importantly i'm going to
surround myself with the right people so
when i started looking into property
your name came up the most so straight
away i didn't faff about i reached out
to you asked for a call and i already
knew my stuff on the course so we had a
good chat we got along pretty well i
thought and and then i thought right
what value can i bring to you you love
your content so i'll make content for
you if i can shadow you i won't get in
your way i'll just make content for you
you'll like the content it'll be really
positive you'll be honest and if you
like it you can post it and in return i
get to follow you around for a few days
and learn everything like what i learned
in them three days shadowing you was
more than i learned in 10 bucks so
surrounding yourself with the right
people and being a constant sponge
that's all it is just the hunger to
learn the minute you stop learning
because you think you know everything is
the minute you think that's amazing so
basically you just get the best people
in different avenues learn from them and
then work your ass off and get the
results absolutely development's not
easy people might think like i've just
come into this and put money in and
hired the right people like finding the
right team can be difficult but it is
the most important thing getting a good
project manager if you've got one hiring
the right local builder and i know
you've used a lot of the academy
students yeah yeah pretty much everybody
in your team has actually gone through
the academy yeah yeah which is which is
amazing all in manchester yeah um so i'm
excited about your steps up moving
forward
so massive respect
well done well done and thank you you're
welcome guys i hope you found this video
helpful massive thank you to liv for
showing us around and letting us be part
of the learning uh if you enjoy the
channel then of course you know what to
do subscribe hit like drop a comment and
we'll see you next time
hey
[Music]